[Müzik]
[Alkış]
ve
[Müzik]
bu
ben renk
Tamam
ve onları
herkes
Evet
Onlar çocuk
[Müzik]
Ben
Hayır
onları görebilirsiniz
ben daha granier
[Müzik]
ben değillim
Y
o
iki saat
geliştirilmiş
bana bak
Evet
bir hediye
Y
milyonlarca
Görelim
şarap ve iyileştirme için
burada nasıl yapıyoruz
kontrol
çıktı
Evet
kulağa nasıl geliyor
çünkü nerede yaşamak
Merhaba
bir dakikalığına
geç
[Müzik]
Y
veya grup
ve ben
Y
benim renklerim
zaman aşk
dakika
Hayır
Ne
Diyorum
nerede
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
ve alan
şimdi evet
sen doktor değilsin
dokunuyoruz
iyiler
insanlar için
bana baktıklarında
[Müzik]
Hadi gidelim
konuşuyor
Y
çok erken bir pazar
D
Ne
[Müzik]
şimdi seni seviyoruz
şeyler
[Müzik]
D
Y
Hayır
bence çok daha fazlası
hepsi için
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Yapabilmek
Giriş
ve
şimdi
kendimize dikkat ettiğimizde
vardır
yukarı çıktım
benim adıma
ile
Evet
[Alkış]